you can't experience the the joy that is
intended for you in life if you don't go
unless you understand that you've got to
parent yourself you got push yourself
you're not gonna make your dreams come
true before my 30 years old I'm a
failure
people lose by never give up what's that
belief Asianet 7 I believe in you and
this channel is designed to be a part of
your daily success routine so today to
help you live your best belief life
let's learn the 10 skills that you must
master to attract success also if you
want to know what will Smith Mel Robbins
Eric Thomas and others have to say about
building unstoppable confidence check
out my 250 for confidence series where
every day for the next 254 days I will
send you a morning video for free to
help you build your confidence the link
to join is in the description below
I was excited about taking a shot the
fact that it was so strange I know that
everybody's problem comes down to one
pattern you're repeating that you can't
see I have boundaries
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one learn to fully commit with Will
Smith life is hard right like yeah you
might get hurt it's like you know you're
you your heart might get broken you know
it's like you might lose your job but
you still gotta commit you know it's
like you know you meet somebody and you
have you know you like her and she likes
you and you hesitating don't hesitate go
commit you gotta commit you know you
might get hurt you might lose something
but it's like you can't experience the
the joy that is intended for you in life
if you don't go you gotta go man
rule number two push yourself with Mel
Robbins you're never ever ever ever
going to feel like doing the things you
need to do in order to have what you
want you're always going to need to push
yourself you're always going to need to
parent yourself so what is the net
advice on this what what is the bottom
line the bottom line is no one's coming
no one no one's coming to push you no
one's coming to tell you to turn the TV
off no one's coming to tell you to get
out the door and exercise nobody's
coming to tell you to apply for that job
that you've always dreamt about nobody's
coming to write the business plan for
you it's up to you and because you're
only ever gonna do the things that you
feel like doing right now or that feel
good right now unless you understand
that you've got to parent yourself you
got to push yourself
you're not gonna make your dreams come
true you're just not we're not wired
that way you weren't born that way you
weren't that way when you were growing
up and you're certainly not that way as
an adult and there's a tremendous amount
of liberation that comes when you accept
the fact that you're always going to
need to give yourself a push rule number
three persevere with
that's a young boy I never thought you
know it's a young boy if ever today I
never thought I would be here honestly I
never thought but as a young boy I
probably when I look back every problems
I met in my when I was a kid
benefited me I filled so many times
people probably know that I've applied
jobs for so many jobs over 30 jobs all
rejected not even got a chance 24 of us
to interview for a KFC job 23 accepted I
was the only got rejected five six
people went fuller looking for a police
job five except I was the only one my
cousin I applied job as a as a as a
server in a full style to my city we
wait a long queue for two hours he was
accepted I really really so my mother
looked at me huh you know yes but I know
this is a training course for me before
my thirty years old I'm a failure of
people lose by never give up I think
there is opportunity there and then I I
was a teacher later I'd read from
University I was teaching the universe
for six years number five because number
five year I was elected the best a
teacher of my universe elected by
students so I said everything I taught
my students are the things I learned
from books what if I go out spend a ten
years experience all the things rather
fail or succeed I'd go back to teach
again that was my original thing and
doing Alibaba so I never thought I could
be rich I never thought it would be
successful I never thought we could
survive for eighteen years and then we
made it
rule number four focus on your strengths
with Oprah Winfrey I've done magazines
you've done movies you've done
television
have you ever wanted to release a CD of
music oh honey please no I you know what
I think one of the things I learned
growing up watching other people like
Johnny Carson for example was was a
mentor in a way because he always
understood what he could and could not
do and I truly understand that that is
not something I could do I mean I
attempted it just as a fun thing a
couple years ago run on run on I got
stuck here myself that's why we that's
why we cut it off I wished I could it's
the one thing I wish I could do but I
think it's a gift to be able to sing and
that's not what I was given
but since I was given so many other rule
number five ignore the opinions of
others with Gary Vaynerchuk on a bigger
macro patience and failure they all
ladder up to one thing which is
insecurity the reason people don't put
themselves in a position to fail the
reason people aren't patient is they
value other people's opinions too much
which then dictates their behavior which
then gets into all of this
Wise's if you like don't hold on to it
and with the thought of in case it fails
because you just need to realize it's
your Scarlet Letter literally the reason
people are scared always is the outside
force having a failing business and
everyone's like Oh see you could never
do or whatever the cliche is right yeah
it just doesn't matter you know why so
that's one piece even if it didn't
succeed
what there's such better people like
what I'm such a better person than other
people because I can build a business
that's [ __ ]
rule number six constantly improve
yourself with pony robins you can't have
a standard education and expect to have
an extraordinary life it's not gonna
happen the one breakthrough for all
leaders is constant never-ending
improvement and that means educating
yourself and continuing to develop even
greater emotional mastery because that's
what affects whether you execute enough
the opportunity for self education is
there we have to change our psychology
from I'm gonna do what everybody else
does
and I'm mad because it doesn't work
anymore - the reality is is the greatest
time to be alive if you're growing
you're learning you're educating and
you're developing valuable skills it's
like if you go to work for McDonald's I
don't know I think the average I read
recently is seven dollars and seventy
five cents an hour in the United States
working for McDonald's the skill sets
the value you provide can be taught to
anyone in about 20 minutes instead of
complaining you gotta say where are the
skill sets valued in the marketplace and
how do I work harder on myself than
anything else because if I become more
valuable then I will be able to give
more do more and change more my
interview Warren Buffett asked the most
important investment you ever made in
his life you already said it was I was
thinking all the companies they've done
you know he said Tony going to Dale
Carnegie said what he goes because by
developing myself that's the most
important investment those skill sets
learning how to persuade learning how to
speak learning and influence all my
ideas would have died on my lips if I
hadn't be able to influence and I
learned it from that little course most
valuable thing every day in my life he
said rule number seven believing
yourself with Dan Locke when I was in my
20s so and it's not the first mastermind
grandma my mastermind group I joined
which is awesome it's by organized by my
mentor Alan so he had this marketing
mastermind group I was in my 20s I was
the youngest guy I'm not supposed to get
in because I'm a minty so he kind of put
me in there yeah kind of us almost my
sake it's just a tag-along right yeah
and I remember sitting around with all
these millionaires yeah all these guys
they were successful I was making like I
don't know nothing makes it nothing
but maybe maybe 80,000 90,000 a year
something like that I was looking at
these guys you know the biggest thing
thing I got out of it not to put them
down they're not that smart
yeah there was it do you think they're
not that smart
yeah like the whatever they're talking
about I get and it's not like rocket
science
yeah dad that's right believe it's like
hey maybe I guess it maybe I could do
that to ya that's all you need maybe I
could do that too yeah that's a starting
point that's the spark right
that's plenty to see then you can go
from there okay now what are they do
what resources do I then do I need food
I have to be in order to do to become
that person yes
rule number eight don't rely on wishful
thinking with Elon Musk young people
nobody want to be like LM moss what's
your advice of it I think that probably
they shouldn't want to be hey you
I think it sounds better than it is okay
yeah it's not as much fun being me as
you'd think
I don't know you don't think so yeah
this definitely it could be worse for
sure
but it's I I I'm not sure I would
I'm not sure I want to be me
but if
you know I think advice I mean if you
want to make progress and things I think
that but the the best analytical
framework for us and in the future is
physics
I'd recommend studying the the thinking
process around physics like not just not
the equations I mean the equations
certainly they're helpful but the the
way of thinking in physics is the that's
the best framework for understanding
things that are counterintuitive and and
you know always taking the position that
you are some degree wrong and your goal
is to be less wrong over time the one of
the biggest mistakes people generally
make and I'm guilty of a two is wishful
thinking you know like you want
something to be true even if it isn't
true and so you ignore other things that
you ignore the real truth because of
what you want to be true this is a very
difficult trap to avoid and like I said
certainly one that I find myself in
having problems with but if you just
take that approach of you're always to
some degree wrong and your goal is to be
less wrong and and solicit critical
feedback particularly from friends like
friends particularly friends if somebody
loves you they want the best for you
they don't want to tell you the bad
things so you have to ask them okay you
know it said really I really do want to
know and then they'll tell you rule
number nine set goals properly with
Jordan Peterson tell your kid here is an
impossible thing why don't you go out
and fail you say here's something worth
going after here's a step you could take
that would push you beyond where you are
but that you also have a reasonably high
probability of succeeding at right they
called that within a time frame
yes and sometime frankly that's the
other thing you have to parameterize it
with regards to time frame that's right
and that puts you in the zone of
proximal development and that's
that's a concept that was generated by a
guy named Vygotsky he was a Russian
developmental psychologist and the smart
one that's where the idea of the zone
comes from to be in the zone and when
you're in the zone you're expanding your
skills in a manner that's intrinsically
rewarding because you're succeeding and
so you want to set if you're good to
yourself you think okay I need to set a
goal but I need to set a goal that
someone is stupid and useless as me
could probably attain if they put some
effort into it and then you got it then
you've got it perfectly because it's not
so high that it's grandiose or
impossible that you fail necessarily and
then justify your bitterness it's like
well I couldn't do it well because that
happens to Pete how much all the time
yeah it's like this all the time you
know it's like it's yes exactly well I
set a goal and I didn't attain it so I'm
not gonna set any more goal right it's
like no you set a goal that was
inappropriate for the time frame that's
right you didn't calibrate it properly
and and you're playing a trick on
yourself because you wanted to fail so
that you could justify not having to try
that's why I'm being a victim mm-hm yeah
which isn't in helpful you're still
gonna be a victim like there's no way
out of that man so you know because life
is this life is a challenge that in some
sense can't be surmounted so there's no
way out of your problem
but there are certainly proper ways of
dealing with it yeah I know number ten
the last one before a very special bonus
clip is develop a growth mindset with
Eric Thomas one thing that bothers me
like right now in life you know life
would be so great for me man I promise
you if I could fix this one thing but my
biggest challenge is he said to fix
mindset you know the growth mindset is
that I gotta hang with people that don't
have my mindset man it's just so it's
just so hard man you know because you
know people think you bougie
I'm not trying to be bougie you know but
a lot of my people that I love I'm late
myself I spend time you know away from a
lot of people and it's like you're ain't
mad at y'all but I want to win 82 games
man I want to win 82 games I want to win
every playoff get I want to sweep every
doggone team I want to win the doggone
championship and you get with people who
you make it to the league if they make
it and that's enough for them and a lot
of people like you know my I had a
conversation my boy called me the other
day and it just was so rough you know
because it was like yo ain't trying to
lead none of y'all but I ain't trying to
die being with y'all you know I'm saying
like and I got a make what a lot of
humans don't realize I got to make so
many sacrifices to be with you you know
I'm saying anything and it ain't like
I'm trying to be better than you or I'm
a bad dude but like let's just be real
Josh we stand at the montage you know
I'm saying my girl was like we spent a
lot like did he sit down like she was
like it cost for three days I have a
long we staying 10 grand
I'm like no question yeah so it ain't
like I got nothin against nobody Josh
but when I travel I don't want to be at
the Holiday Inn Express
yep no question I did that already I
paid my dues I stayed I stayed in the
motel 6 bro I was in the kingdom when I
first started speaking do you feel me
and I started when I was 19
bruh we was driving 1012 hours yeah 16
hours I don't want to do that at 47 and
the fact that you didn't grow or usually
you want to stay where you are
I'm not mad at you but I get I get angry
with people because you trying to make
me feel bad because I I want to grow
bright like I wake up every day and I
want to be better than what I was the
day before so if I go to a restaurant
and I want to I want eggs Brown went to
a restaurant the other day it was like
three o'clock in the afternoon but I was
at Wyndham Hotel where they ain't oh no
we don't serve eggs yeah they not own
that they like we here for you that's
the difference in the hotel Holiday Inn
Express they telling me we'll serve that
will D sir that from 6:00 to 11:00
the montage they like you want scrambled
eggs with cheese okay how many eggs you
want okay what else do you eat well I'm
eating soy we got soy too we got
everything
and don't come downstairs bring it down
we bring it up so I just want to say you
know for real man that's the one thing
in my life right now that that if I had
a magic wand I would fix I want to be
with everybody yeah but I can't be
around
average and you can't be mad at me
because I don't we it's like what Jamal
said all right want to get property
that's what he does I don't want to be
around people who don't want to take
risks yeah
not because I'm mad at you but you you
bottle me up yeah you making me not
right I want to fly
you cannot invent and pioneer if you
cannot accept failure its you to invent
you need to experiment and if it's if
you know in advance that it's going to
work it is not an experiment and so
that's a very important thing you know
it's these they're inseparable twins
failure and invention it's so you have
to be willing to do that it's
embarrassing to fail you know it's
always embarrassing to fail but you have
to say no that's not how this works if I
said to you you have a 10% chance of a
with a particular decision a 10% chance
of a 100x return you should take that
bet every time but you're still gonna be
wrong nine out of ten times and it's
gonna feel bad nine out of ten times and
in in in with technology the outcomes
the results can be very long tailed they
it's very at the payoff is can be very
asymmetric which is why you should do so
much experimentation you know everybody
knows that if you swing for the fences
you hit more home runs but you also
strike out more but with the baseball
that analogy doesn't go far enough
because with baseball no matter how well
you connect with the ball you can only
get four runs the success is capped at
four runs but in business every once in
a while
you step up to the plate you hit the
ball so hard you get a thousand runs and
so when that when you have that kind of
asymmetric payoff and you know one app
one app back and get you a thousand runs
it encourages you to experiment more
it's the right business decision to
experiment more it's also better for
your customers customers like the
successful experiments raise your
standard Apple at the cool
core value is that even that people have
passion can change the way people not
one drop of myself work depends on
Europe it's supposed to mean
if you liked this video and want more
check out the 20 best pieces of advice
that every aspiring entrepreneur needs
to hear the link is right there next to
me continue to believe and I'll see you
there and to work on the alignment of
your personality